lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es dar
un poco de intuición acerca de por qué
el teorema del binomio está tan
involucrado con la combinatoria en
especial porque los coeficientes de los
términos son las combinaciones de un
exponente en otro exponente y aquí
estamos empezando con un ejemplo muy
sencillo que es x + a la tercera
potencia lo cual es simplemente x + 9
por x + d por x + y ya sabemos
perfectamente cómo se ve la expansión de
este binomio al cubo generalmente
empezamos escogiendo una equis de cada
uno de los paréntesis y multiplicando
los y nos queda x al cubo y si escogimos
3x escogimos una equis de cada
paréntesis entonces en ningún paréntesis
escogimos una y así es que no escogimos
ni una sola y y entonces nos preguntamos
cuántas formas hay de escoger
de tres paréntesis tres paréntesis ni
una sola y ni una sola llegue y esto de
aquí las combinaciones de tres en cero
es el coeficiente del término x la tres
por llegar a cero y bueno todos sabemos
que hay exactamente una forma de de cada
paréntesis es [ __ ] una equis y esto es
equivalente a de todos los paréntesis no
escoger ni una sola ya que es lo que
queremos porque tenemos aquí ya a las
cero y las combinaciones de tres en cero
si son iguales a 1 y esto es lo que
obtendríamos si hiciéramos la extensión
de esta multiplicación aunque tendríamos
un solo término que tiene x al cubo y
ahora vamos con el siguiente término que
tiene x cuadrada porque a la 1 aunque
hay entonces tenemos aquí tres canastas
con un adicional de cada uno y de esas
tres canastas tenemos que escoger un
elemento de cada una de tal forma que
tengamos dos equis y una y
y eso es equivalente a tomar las
combinaciones de tres en uno aunque aquí
estamos diciendo tal cual tenemos un
conjunto de tres canastas y vamos a
escoger a una sola canasta que puede ser
esta esta o esta de tal forma que esa
sea la canasta elegida para que saquemos
de ahí la aie y en el resto de las
canastas vamos a sacar puras x entonces
esa canasta de la cual sacamos la y
puede ser esta esa es una forma o puede
ser que saquemos la lleve esta canasta y
saquemos puras x de estos dos paréntesis
esa es la segunda forma o puede ser que
saquemos la aie de esta canasta y de
estas dos canastas saquemos puras equis
y esa es la tercera forma entonces se
hay y las combinaciones de tres en uno
es igual a tres formas de sacar la
multiplicación de a la 1 por x al
cuadrado también lo podemos pensar como
que tienes tres amigos pero sólo uno de
ellos va a ser tu mejor amigo
entonces pues hay tres formas de escoger
a ese mejor amigo bueno vamos con el
siguiente término ahora tenemos ya al
cuadrado por equis a la 1 y cuántas
formas tenemos que hacer este producto
pues tenemos 3 paréntesis 3 paréntesis y
tenemos que escoger dos de esos
paréntesis dos de esos paréntesis para
de ellos sacar dos jets y en el otro
vamos a sacar una equis ok puede ser que
de este paréntesis saquemos una y de
este paréntesis saquemos otra y y de
este paréntesis saquemos una equis y eso
nos da una forma de hacer este producto
de equis porque al cuadrado o podemos
escoger esta y esta x y esta otra y y
eso también nos da x porque al cuadrado
esta es la segunda forma o podemos
escoger esta x de este paréntesis y
escoger que este paréntesis nos dé una i
este otro paréntesis nos de otra y esa
es la última forma de hacer el producto
de x porque al cuadrado entonces de 3
paréntesis escogemos que dos de ellos
nos den una i y el tercero nos dé una
equis y por eso hay las combinaciones de
tres en dos formas de hacer este
producto que también lo podemos ver como
que estás lleno de paseo con tus amigos
y tú te estás sentando en medio del
coche y hay dos lugares a tu lado
entonces de tus tres amigos quiénes son
los dos que se van a sentar a tu lado
todo el trayecto claro si no te importa
quién está a la derecha y quién está a
la izquierda pero bueno vamos con el
último término de esta expansión del
binomio al cubo
finalmente cuántas formas hay de escoger
de los tres paréntesis trelles aunque
hoy tenemos tres paréntesis y tenemos
que escoger 33 pues hay simplemente una
forma de escoger 13 es no todos los
paréntesis nos tienen que dar una y y si
de todos
si escogemos una y entonces no vamos a
tener ni una sola equis y pues hay una
sola forma de escoger de cada paréntesis
una y ok y las combinaciones de tres en
tres es igual a 1 si es que todo está
muy bien y por eso es que tenemos estas
combinaciones de tres en tantos en el
teorema del binomio lo que hay aquí
tenemos las combinaciones de tres en
tres porque de cada uno de los tres
paréntesis que tenemos aquí que
multiplicar tenemos que escoger que tres
de esos paréntesis nos dan una y y el
resto nos dé una equis ok pero si de
tres paréntesis tenemos que escoger tres
paréntesis pues simplemente hay una sola
forma de hacer eso y lo mismo para acá
tenemos aquí ya al cuadrado entonces de
tres paréntesis tenemos que escoger el
segundo término o sea la y en dos de
ellos únicamente y pues hay tres formas
de hacer eso lo mismo para que de tres
paréntesis tenemos que escoger el
segundo término
únicamente en uno de los tres paréntesis
entonces hay exactamente tres formas de
hacer eso y finalmente de tres
paréntesis no escoger ningún paréntesis
hay exactamente una forma de hacer eso